[Applaus]
das war das erste und herzlich
willkommen zu einem video leute hat es
mich ganz besonders freuen denn wir
werden heute serien an ihrem intro
erraten und es wird sich definitiv die
einfach eine kinderserie einschleichen
und ich wir werden bei traurige
fröhliche kinder 10 euro ab selbst wer
bin ich eigentlich lassen sich zu viel
aber das ist direkt anfangen max und ich
so um jeweils im bus war aus spielen wie
man dann vor und da man muss versuchen
jetzt das ist das ziel
ich würde sagen einfach damit man so
weit dass man das auch wirklich erkannt
hat gespräch so ziehen sie von acht oder
sogar wenn ich kann für so weiter zu
singen aber auf jeden fall zu sein das
ist
[Applaus]
die sogar die serie verkehr t ich habe
auch was ich habe was was richtig geiles
alter
und sagt ich hab das ist irgendwie das
gezeichnete ich ferien machen wir weiter
man muss sich anstrengen dass sie
einfach zu meinen mitbürgern
wie geil alter für mich die ganz große
leute ich liebe dieses video jetzt schon
dass man sofort hätte ja ich bin zu
denken ist mir egal wie lang ist diese
aufnahme her
[Musik]
pagemasters war lok 1965 ist also leute
wisst ihr noch besser trägt damals die
eltern haben immer gesagt nicht mal der
sandmann und da hat er den schlafsand
ausgeworfen zeigte ja ich habe einfach
nicht hingeschaut
das war das motto der viehhalter die
jürgen rieger
das war so ein richtiger sport so als
kind gehört dem auszuweiten
man hat immer so geschaut man wollt ihr
sehen was der markt aber sobald man
gemerkt hat auch jetzt wird er gleich
immer und dann war man nicht müde
[Musik]
video youtube habe ich so krass gesucht
wird um ein deutscher ist immer so wie
die tracks serien war
biotest leute keine dritte halbzeit
super da fehlte dieses leicht verletzt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
pokémon patrick thaler die täter kannte
ich gedacht ich würde hier nicht über
das ist klar das ist so ein typ der
immer sogar abenteuer hat
ich kenne das ok aber was ist das alter
um mein gott nicht die schnellsten alle
schreiben mitteilte duschbad warte warte
auf halbmast gebrüder grimm sind sie
drin ja nächsten drei punkte die wir
machen daraus spaß heute ist nicht so
wettbewerbsfähig ist einfach nur so
kindheitstagen begann wie geil sind anna
grimm aber kurz früheren sind sie da
sind
oder das video via
[Applaus]
in jedem an
[Musik]
[Applaus]
oh ja wann
das waren aber noch kein thema
doch warte ich habe einige ideen ich
habe zwei serien im kopf ich sage nils
holgersson ja mal alte das ist auch so
christkindes vollgas das musste
[Musik]
nils holgersson fucking legende auf ok
ok wat du bist auf dem level jetzt mir
kommen naja denkst du ich kann da nicht
mithalten das nächste schon
ich hab das nicht sind hätte auch
legende aber jetzt abbekommen denn
bedeutet wenn ich im club wird und der
sound kommt
klar würde die den zusammengeschlagen
oder drastisch aus
das kind denn bei heidi ab alter heidi
was ist das für eine kranke schaukel
alter ab so dass von diesen kein video
einfach das aber einfach warm ums herz
bei summen wie die leute das war bockig
hoffentlich auch gefallen so weit mag
ich gerne vernimmt heute hier könnt hier
doch ja da erscheint gerade ihr könnt
jetzt hier noch erfolgen was das geht ab
checken erst einmal videos auf den
märkten hat vielleicht das gerne
[Musik]